les tensions diplomatiques entre la
France et le Niger menacent-elles
l'approvisionnement de la France en
uranium l’uranium notamment nécessaire
pour faire tourner les centrales
nucléaires étaient l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles la France se trouvait au
Niger Orano entreprise détenue par
l'état français extraits
du pays proche de la frontière
algérienne en 2021 2248 tonnes d'uranium
avait été extraites du Niger 6e pays
extracteur derrière la Russie
l'Ouzbékistan l'Australie le Canada la
Namibie est loin devant tous ces états
le Kazakhstan où sont extraits près de
10 fois plus de métal entre avril 2022
et avril 2023 la France a rapporté près
de 10000 tonnes d'uranium dont environ
2/3 sont consommés par les centrales
nucléaires et le tiers restant revendu
par Orano à l'étranger ces 10 Milton
proviennent de six pays différents en
tête des fournisseurs de la France on
retrouve le Kazakhstan puis
l'Ouzbékistan et le Niger tout droit
dans des par similaires puis l'Australie
la Namibie et pas l'Afrique du Sud au
début des années 2000 EDF avait
volontairement diversifié ses
fournisseurs dans un souci de sécurité
d'approvisionnement comme le rappelle
importe parole de l'entreprise au Figaro
mais avec ses 2126 tonnes fournis à la
France soit 18% et près d'un cinquième
de l'uranium à portée le Niger rend-il
la France dépendante concrètement non et
pour plusieurs raisons si le Niger
venait à interrompre les exportations
d'uranium ce qui n'est pas le cas à
l'heure actuelle la France pourrait se
tourner vers d'autres partenaires soit
en modifiant ces contrats long terme
soit en recours en marché internationaux
comme l'explique aux Figaro anacrity
professeur d'économie à Paris Dauphine
de plus l'uranium n'est pas une
ressource rare beaucoup de territoires
disposent de grandes quantités du métal
enfin au titre des stocks stratégiques
prévus par l'État EDF dispose d'au moins
deux ans de réserve d'uranium naturel à
cela s'ajoutent les stocks d'uranium
appauvri que la France s'est enrichir au
total la France dispose d'un stock
d'uranium lui permettant de couvrir ses
besoins pendant une décennie
[Musique]